while breaking news for you know in the
15 year old Russian figure skater who
was allowed to stay and compete at the
Winter Olympics despite a failed drugs
test last year has missed out on a medal
in the individual final coming fourth
after making a number of errors in her
routine well our Sports correspondent
Tom Parmenter joins me now so Tom did
the pressure get to her then in the end
or the talk in Beijing before this
figure skating final was that you either
get 100 at Camilla valeeva and she's
just Flawless or you get something
drastically wrong and and really that is
what we saw she fell several times
during her final routine she was
expected to be amongst the medals but
those Falls cost her and she finished
fourth in the end in the individual
competition so after all of the
discussion around her continuing to
participate in the Winter Olympics given
the fact that we know that she tested
positive for a banned the substance in
December of last year
all of that controversy and all of that
pressure I think showed and it cracked
the final performance and it was a mess
and she swiped the air with her hand as
she finished the performance there were
tears and she blew that big opportunity
such expectation on her she is one of
the most talented skaters on the planet
but it all went so badly wrong in
Beijing in that final appearance that
she was making this lunch time and it is
a cruel end and it's really a position
that a 15 year old should never really
have been put into and the authorities
and the games organizers will have a lot
of questions to to face around it but
the flip side of it is that three other
skaters another two Russians and one of
the Japanese skaters make it into the
top three there is a Russian at the in
the gold medal position and those
skaters will get Justice because they
will get their medal ceremony that they
wouldn't have had if valerieva had been
in the top three so one of the most
dramatic Olympic finals in recent memory
and Valley ever crashes out of that
final finishes fourth in the competition
and leaves these Winter Games to try to
pick her way through a drugs inquiry and
doping inquiry that she is still at the
center of she did win in a gold with her
team and the team competition earlier in
these games which is still very much
pending those medals haven't been
presented yet but all of the eyes of the
sporting world were on valiava in this
final today the individual competition
and it crumbled around her very very
upsetting and I think while of course
you have a 15 year old at the heart of
this and there is something of a tragedy
around that there is also the fact that
those skaters who have worked so hard
have gone on to the podium will actually
get their moments with their medals in
Beijing after this competition